سأتحدث الآن عن القنابل العنقودية
بينما أنت معي، سيدي الوزير،
اتخذ الرئيس بايدن
القرار المثير للجدل للغاية بتوفير
هذه الذخائر العنقودية
إلى أوكرانيا. هل ستتمكن أوكرانيا من
تحقيق ما الذي ستتمكن من تحقيقه؟  يمكنك
تحقيق هذه القنابل العنقودية في ساحة المعركة باستخدام
هذه الذخائر العنقودية
التي يمكن أن تبرر المخاطر
الموجودة هناك، وأنت على
دراية بالقنابل العنقودية التي تمثل خطرًا على
المدنيين على الطريق
أم أن هذا قتال مدفعي مكثف كما
تعلم أننا قد  رأينا أه
كميات كبيرة من المدفعية يتم استخدامها على
جانبي السياج وهذا يضع
ضغطًا على الإمداد الدولي أه أه ذخائر
المدفعية
وهكذا بالترتيب وما فعلناه في وقت
مبكر هو أننا قمنا بإشراك
قاعدتنا الصناعية و  طلبت منهم توسيع
طاقتهم وأيضا أه
القاعدة الصناعية الدولية لقد عملنا مع
دول أخرى للقيام بنفس الشيء أه
لدينا ما نحتاج إليه وأه
وسنستمر في الحصول على ما نحتاجه
لدعم مصانعنا الولايات المتحدة
أمريكا ولكن أه لكننا نريد التأكد من
أن أوكرانيا لديها ما تحتاجه
لتتمكن من مواصلة القتال أثناء
حدوث هذا التوسع هذه أه
هذه الذخائر العنقودية تعمل كنوع من
القدرة على التجسير أه أه ولذلك نريدها أن  تكون
قادرة على مواصلة الضغط على
العدو أه طوال الوقت ودعم
محطات المناورة ولهذا السبب
اتخذ الرئيس هذا أه هذا
أه قرار متعمد
لتوفير هذا ولكنك تدرك
المخاطر المحتملة التي تشكلها هذه
القنابل العنقودية هناك إذا  إذا لم
تنفجر على الطريق، فمن المحتمل أن
تنفجر إذا تُركت في المناطق وقد
يكون هناك أطفال ومدنيون رجال
ونساء وأطفال يمكن أن يتعرضوا للقتل
أو الإصابة نتيجة لهذه
الذخائر، ولهذا السبب أكثر  لقد حظرت أكثر من 100
دولة، بما في ذلك العديد من حلفاء الناتو،
استخدام هذه
القنابل العنقودية. أنا أعرف
كيف تعمل هذه الذخائر. لقد
استخدمتها بالفعل في القتال الذي
ارتكبه الأوكرانيون أولاً.
أعتقد أننا يجب أن نتذكر أنهم
يقاتلون بشدة.  للدفاع عن
أراضيهم السيادية، تعلم أنهم لا يطلبون
الذخائر لغزو
دولة أخرى كما فعل الروس، لقد كانوا
يستخدمون الذخائر العنقودية
منذ البداية كما تعلم،
ويبلغ معدل الوفيات في ذخائرهم
حوالي 30  إلى 40 في المائة وهو أمر
رائع للغاية لكن الأوكرانيين
تعهدوا كتابيًا بالتأكد من أن
هذه الذخائر تستخدم فقط في
الأماكن المناسبة ولا تستخدم ضد
المراكز السكانية وسوف يسجلون
الأماكن التي يستخدمونها فيها وسيعطون
الأولوية لجهود إزالة الألغام و
وسنساعدهم على القيام بذلك في تلك الأماكن
التي استخدموا فيها هذه الظروف.
ما هي المدة التي تعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة ستحتاجها
لتوفير هذه القنابل العنقودية لأوكرانيا؟
نريد التأكد من أن أوكرانيا يمكن أن
تظل ناجحة في قتالها مع
الذئاب.  ولذا تعلمون أنني لن أتكهن
بالمدة التي سيستغرقها ذلك،
سنواصل التركيز على
التأكد من حصولهم على ما يحتاجون إليه اه
اه لمواصلة تقديم الدعم
لمناوراتهم واه وهكذا
هذا هو
ما كنا عليه منذ البداية
وسنواصل التركيز على ما هي
أكبر التحديات، سيدي الوزير، التي
يواجهها الجيش الأوكراني الآن
عندما يبدأون ويواصلون
هجومهم المضاد ضد
الروس الذين يقومون بتطهير حقول الألغام  لقد كان الذئب
أه هو التحدي الأكبر الذي يواجههم
اليوم وأه إنهم يقومون بذلك لقد قاموا
بعملية متعمدة للغاية في القيام بذلك حتى
يتمكنوا من الحفاظ على
القوى العاملة، ولا يزال لديهم الكثير من
القدرات المتبقية فيما يتعلق  أه القوات
متوفرة أه لكن أه لكن تطهير حقول
الألغام هو ما يمثل
التحدي الأكبر لهم حتى الآن كيف يتم
الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني
الآن سأسمح للأوكرانيين بالتحدث معهم أه
تقديم تقييمهم الخاص لكيفية
سير الأمور أه لكن لكن  مرة أخرى
يواصلون الضغط على لقد علمنا
بالمناسبة منذ البداية أن
هذه ستكون معركة صعبة للغاية، لقد
سمعتني أقول ذلك الذئب، لقد سمعت
الجنرال ميلر يقول ذلك
وستظل معركة صعبة أه  وعندما
يقومون
بتطهير حقول الألغام هذه،
سيتبعون نهجًا متعمدًا للغاية تجاه هذا الأمر،
وبمجرد القيام بذلك مرة أخرى، سيكون
لديهم الكثير من القوات المتاحة التي يمكنهم الحصول عليها، حيث
يمكنهم المناورة حيث سيتم
تسليم الطائرات المقاتلة من طراز F-16 إلى  أوكرانيا
تقف الآن، أعلم أن حلفاء الناتو
يدربون الطيارين الأوكرانيين على الطيران بطائرات
F-16، لكن التسليم الفعلي
أين يقف هذا جيدًا، علينا أن
نعلمك كما تعلم أن هذا
يتضمن عددًا من الخطوات أولاً وقبل كل شيء
عليك  لتدريب الطيارين في
هولندا وفي الدنمارك
يقودون هذا الجهد، وقد انضم عدد من
البلدان الأخرى إلى ذلك في
ذلك الاتحاد لكنهم
ينظرون أيضًا أثناء قيامهم بذلك، ونحن نعلم أنه
يتعين علينا إجراء صيانة  القدرة،
لذا فهم يقومون أيضًا بتدريب المشرفين أيضًا،
ثم هناك استدامة
تتماشى معها، ثم هناك
تحسينات عليها في
المطارات ولذا هناك عدد من
الأشياء التي يجب أن تحدث وهذا اه
هذا لا  'لا يحدث ذلك خلال أيام ويستغرق الأمر
أشهرًا لتحقيق هذه
القدرة ولكن مرة أخرى، تقوم هولندا والدنمارك بعمل
جدير بالثقة، عمل رائع ويخرجان ويطلبان
مساعدة الدول الأخرى
وسيوفران تلك القدرة
بأسرع ما يمكن، لا يمكننا أن
نعطيني جدولًا زمنيًا عندما
تصل تلك الطائرات المقاتلة الأولى من طراز F-16،
سأسمح لهم بالتحدث نيابةً عنك، لمعرفة
وتيرة الجهود المبذولة هناك ولكن
هذا رائع، لقد حصلنا على  لتدريب الطيارين
أولاً ثم القيام ببعض
الأشياء الأخرى، كما تعلم أن بعض
الجمهوريين اليمينيين المتطرفين أه في المنزل
يحاولون استخدام
مشروع قانون الدفاع السنوي لقطع التمويل عن أوكرانيا على سبيل
المثال وصفته عضوة الكونجرس مارجوري تايلور
جرين بذلك  خط أحمر إلى أي مدى
يقوض ذلك مساعي الرئيس بايدن من أجل
الوحدة في واشنطن فيما يتعلق بدعم
أوكرانيا، حسنًا،
نأمل بالتأكيد أن نكون قد استمتعنا
بدعم الحزبين لأوكرانيا
طوال الذئب ونأمل أن
نحافظ على ذلك  أن دعم
أوكرانيا مهم أوكرانيا مهمة ليس فقط
لأوكرانيا، إنها مهمة للعالم أجمع،
هذا يتعلق بالنظام الدولي القائم على القواعد
وأه والدول في
جميع أنحاء العالم تدرك ذلك ولهذا
السبب تعلمون أننا نجمع الحلفاء
والشركاء معًا أه في  في
جهد مشترك للعمل على تقديم
المساعدة الأمنية لأوكرانيا، ولهذا السبب حصلنا على
عدد كبير جدًا من الأشخاص الذين شاركوا
منذ البداية وما زالوا
يشاركون، وهذا أمر مهم
للعالم أجمع، إنه أمر بالغ الأهمية
بالفعل، فلننتقل إلى روسيا سيدي الوزير
بينما أنا  أنت بعد ذلك
التمرد الفاشل الذي رأيناه جميعًا يتكشف في
روسيا هل تعتقد أن بوتين لديه
القيادة الكاملة للجيش الروسي وهؤلاء
المقاتلين المرتزقة في نفس
الوقت حسنًا أعتقد أه لا أريد
التكهن بما لديه أو ما لديه  لا أود أن
أقول فقط أنني أعتقد أننا
جميعًا أه نعتقد أنه يواجه تحديات، ومن
المؤكد أنه ربما لم يتوقع
هذا النوع من التحديات وسيكون من
المثير للاهتمام أن نرى كيف يتعافى
من هذا أو ما إذا كان يمكنه التعافي أم لا
من ذلك، كما تعلم، على
المدى الطويل، تعتقد أنه قادر على ذلك، فهو
شخص مرن جدًا
ولن أتجاهل أي شيء
ولكن بعد أن قلت إننا سنواصل
التركيز على التأكد من أن
أوكرانيا لديها ما  يجب أن تستمر في
التركيز على هذه المعركة وأن تكون ناجحًا، هل
تعرف أين يوجد أي بريجوسيان،
قائد المرتزقة لمجموعة فاغنر
الآن؟
لا أعلم، لقد
كنت
مندهشًا للغاية لأنه تمكن من التحرك
ومن روسيا وإد سوف
نرى ما سيحدث في المستقبل ولكني
لا أعرف أين هو الآن حسنًا
دعنا نتحدث قليلاً هناك
قضية حساسة قضية حساسة للغاية وقد
واجه البنتاغون بعض الانتقادات الحادة
كما  كما تعلم لأنه يمنع
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية من
الحصول على أدلة أمريكية على جرائم الحرب الروسية
في أوكرانيا، لماذا حسنًا،
دعني أقول مقدمًا إنني
سأدعم أي جهد للتأكد من
أننا نفعل الصواب
أشياء لتقديم مجرمي العمل إلى
العدالة، وكما
تعلم أن هناك عددًا من
الطرق للقيام بذلك ولكنك تعلم أننا
سنواصل أه العمل
مع مجتمع إنتل وآخرين
لتقديم تلك المعلومات  لكن لماذا
لا نقدم هذه المعلومات إلى
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية مرة أخرى،
أه سواء فعلت الولايات المتحدة ذلك أم لا، فهذا
قرار سياسي أه اتخذه
الرئيس، لذا نعم، وأين
موقف وزارة الدفاع من ذلك جيدًا
مهما كان القرار الذي
يتخذه الرئيس  بالطبع سوف ندعم ذلك